the UN wants to evacuate nearly a
hundred patients facing medical
emergencies in a besieged area outside
Syria's capital the Syrian army backed
by Russian airstrikes is targeting rebel
forces in eastern Gudda Syria's
government says the rebels they are
attacking Damascus with rockets Seth
Doane went to a school in Damascus near
the fighting and met some students who
are brave in class even as the war is
raging all around them Seth good morning
good morning this school is just a
couple of miles from rebel-held goethe
which puts it dangerously close to the
front lines it was hit by a mortar and
ten other mortars fell in just a day
across the street and today like many
days a number of kids simply didn't show
up one thousand students used to gather
in the open courtyard for the morning
pledge that's when there were that many
students and when it was safe to stand
outside this morning classrooms were
less than half full as frightened
parents kept kids home do you ever get
used to the sounds of rockets mortars
planes yeah it just becomes everyday
Rose Khalid dreams of studying in Boston
to become a doctor
our interview kept being interrupted by
the sound of Warplanes Syrian forces and
their allies have been targeting rebels
in eastern Goethe where entire schools
hospitals and homes have been destroyed
ten-year-old kala was just three when
the war began she doesn't know much
about politics but does know about fear
what do you do when you are going to hit
on us about 10 percent of the students
here fled from other war-torn places but
war found them again across Syria in
both government and rebel-held areas a
number of schools have been destroyed so
for all of the concerns here at least
this one is still standing
Alex Seth Doane and Damascus thanks a
few know they're cancelling school in
Washington because of wind and her day
is interrupted at school by warplanes we
put things in perspective and you look
at it like that an entire generation of
children has been devastated by this war
in Syria